♫ I have a dream, a song to sing ♫
I'm so glad you're here.
I'm pregnant.
But, I don't know how to do this by myself.
Your mother is the greatest person we ever met.
Look at my baby.
Let me tell you how she did it.
All on her own.
Life is short.
The world is wide.
I want to make some memories.
This dress
might look very pretty on.
Hey, you don't know me at all, do you?
I think we should stay here together.
Oh, I wish I could stay here too.
Turns out, he's engaged.
I hate it when they do that.
♫ I was cheated by you.
♫ And I think you know when.
♫ Look at me now.
♫ Will I ever learn?
♫ I don't know how
♫ but I suddenly lose control.
♫ There's a fire within my soul
Come on girl
I've never felt closer to my mom.
She wasn't scared.
Because she had me.
We can't tell anybody else about the baby, okay?
I just told Bill
Yeah, and I told Harry
And I told many many people.
Let's get the party started.
Grandma, you are invited.
That's the best kind of party, little girl.